When he wants to explain to people what his life is like these days, Lenny sometimes tells this story. On election night in 2016, he says he went to a bar, got a seat near a TV, ordered a beer, and started making small talk.
当Lenny想向别人解释他如今的生活是什么样子时，他有时会讲这个故事。他说在2016年大选之夜，他走进一家酒吧，在电视机旁找了个座位，点了一杯啤酒，开始闲聊。
And I turned to the guy to my right, and I said, "Did you vote"? And from there, he went into a long explanation about-- just some shadow government ideas, and whether voting makes a difference. And probably 10 minutes into it, he was talking about mass shootings, and then eventually Sandy Hook.
我转向右边的那个人问：“你投票了吗？”从那以后，他就开始了一长篇大论——谈论一些影子政府的观点，以及投票到底有没有意义。大概谈了10分钟后，他开始谈论大规模枪击事件，最后谈到了桑迪胡克小学。
Sandy Hook, of course, where a gunman killed 20 children, all in first grade, as well as seven adults. This random stranger then started telling Lenny this particular story about Sandy Hook. He thought the whole shooting was fake. It had to be fake, he said, because one of those first graders also showed up as a victim in a second mass shooting, all the way over in Pakistan.
当然，桑迪胡克小学发生过一起枪击案，一名枪手杀害了20名一年级的孩子和7名成年人。这个陌生人随后开始向Lenny讲述关于桑迪胡克的特定故事。他说，他认为整场枪击案都是假的。他说那一定是假的，因为其中一名一年级学生竟然同时出现在巴基斯坦的另一起大规模枪击案中，成为受害者。
In the corners of the internet where people trade Sandy Hook conspiracy stories, this is a key piece of evidence that Sandy Hook was not real. Of course, it was real. And what happened in Pakistan was, in reality, about two years after Sandy Hook. The Taliban gunned down more than 100 kids there. And there was a public vigil, and at the public vigil, probably as a sign of solidarity with other kids who had died in school shootings, mourners had this photo of a boy from Sandy Hook, smiling and wearing a Spider-Man shirt under a corduroy jacket with a furry collar.
在互联网上那些传播桑迪胡克阴谋论的角落里，这是证明桑迪胡克是虚构的关键证据。当然，它是真实的。而巴基斯坦的那起事件，实际上发生在桑迪胡克事件大约两年后。塔利班在那里枪杀了100多名儿童。当时举行了公开守灵仪式，而在仪式上，哀悼者可能为了表示与在校园枪击案中遇难的其他孩子团结一致，手里拿着一张来自桑迪胡克的男孩的照片，男孩微笑着，穿着印有蜘蛛侠图案的衬衫，外面套着一件带有毛领的灯芯绒夹克。
Sandy Hook deniers saw that in the coverage, and they pounced. "Did he die twice?" "Did he die at all?" So the guy at the bar with Lenny is rattling through all this Pakistan stuff. And then, as Lenny explained to one of my co-workers, Miki Meek, the guy mentions the kid's name-- Noah Pozner.
桑迪胡克阴谋论者在报道中看到了这一点，便立即抓住了它。“他死了两次吗？”“他真的死了吗？”所以，酒吧里那个跟Lenny搭话的人正滔滔不绝地讲述着巴基斯坦的那一堆东西。然后，正如Lenny向我的同事Miki Meek解释的那样，那个人提到了那个孩子的名字——Noah Pozner。
I didn't really need to hear much more than that. I just needed to shut him down, basically.
我真的不需要再听更多了。我基本上只需要让他闭嘴。
So what did you do?
那你做了什么？
I took out my driver's license, and I said, "Look who you're talking to. You know, show some respect."
我拿出我的驾驶执照说：“看看你在跟谁说话。你知道，放尊重点。”
The boy in the photo was Lenny's son, Noah, who was six when he died.
照片里的男孩是Lenny的儿子Noah，他去世时才六岁。
Does he connect it, or--
他把这两件事联系起来了，还是——
Oh, sure. He connected it instantly, yeah. And he just became more agitated. Very angered. Went outside and maybe had a cigarette, came back, yelled at me some more. "Oh my god. How much did they pay you? How can you do this?" He was committed to his belief. I was the villain.
哦，当然。他立刻就联系起来了，是的。他变得更加激动。非常愤怒。走到外面抽了根烟，回来后又对我大吼大叫。“天哪。他们给了你多少钱？你怎么能这么做？”他坚信自己的想法。我成了反派。
People like this man at the bar pretty much redefined everything about the way Lenny lives his life. Where he lives, how he lives. He runs into these hoaxers in person, and pretty much every day online. They think the government has paid him millions to play the part of a grieving dad. In their minds, Lenny is the sick one. Noah wasn't ever even his kid. And the person who has popularized these theories more than anybody is Alex Jones, who runs the website Infowars, and who pushed these theories with his radio show, and his YouTube videos.
像酒吧里那个男人这样的人，几乎重塑了Lenny生活的方方面面。他住哪里，他如何生活。他在线下会遇到这些骗子，在网上也几乎每天都会遇到。他们认为政府付了他数百万美元，让他扮演一个悲伤的父亲的角色。在他们看来，Lenny才是那个有病的人。Noah甚至根本不是他的孩子。而将这些理论传播得比任何人都广的人是Alex Jones，他经营着InfoWars网站，并通过他的电台节目和YouTube视频推销这些理论。
Alex Jones made his name right after 9/11, promoting the idea that 9/11 was an attack orchestrated by our own government. With Sandy Hook, Jones said many times that he did not believe the shooting was real.
Alex Jones在“9·11”事件后成名，宣扬“9·11”是由我们自己的政府策划的袭击这一观点。关于桑迪胡克事件，Jones多次表示他不相信枪击案是真的。
Sandy Hook is a synthetic, completely fake, with actors, in my view, manufactured. I couldn't believe it at first. I knew they had actors there, clearly. But I thought they killed some real kids. And it just shows how bold they are, that they clearly used actors.
在我看来，桑迪胡克事件是一个综合性的、彻头彻尾的骗局，有演员参与，是被人为制造出来的。起初我不敢相信。我知道他们肯定用了演员。但我以为他们杀害了一些真正的孩子。这正说明了他们有多大胆，因为他们明显用了演员。
He's claimed that the government, or some shadowy global forces, are the ones who hired these actors. He and the other hoaxers call them "crisis actors." It's like this whole alternate world that exists right next to the real one. It makes life miserable for parents like Lenny.
他声称政府或某些阴暗的全球势力是聘请这些演员的人。他和那些骗子称他们为“危机演员”。这就像是一个就在现实世界旁边存在的另一个世界。这让像Lenny这样的父母生活变得苦不堪言。
But unlike most parents in that situation, Lenny decided to go all action hero on the hoaxers, and on Alex Jones. Action hero, I will do what needs to get done to defend my family, damn the consequences. Lenny is resourceful. He is dogged. He does not give up. In this world that we live in of hoaxers and trolls, he has marked out a path that I think few of us would ever want to take. But it is kind of amazing to hear what it entails.
但与大多数处于这种情况的父母不同，Lenny决定像动作英雄一样对待那些骗子和Alex Jones。动作英雄，就是为了捍卫家人，不惜一切后果去做必要的事。Lenny足智多谋。他很执着。他从不放弃。在我们这个充满骗子和喷子的世界里，他走出了一条我想我们极少数人会愿意选择的道路。但听到这其中所包含的内容是相当惊人的。
Today on our show, we have Lenny's story. And then we have a story from writer Jon Ronson, where he also tries to untangle where this alternate hoaxer world ends and the real one begins. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述Lenny的故事。然后我们还会有一篇来自作家Jon Ronson的故事，他也试图理清这个虚假的骗子世界在哪里结束，现实世界在哪里开始。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, Down the Rabbit Hole. So our story about the transformation of Lenny Pozner was put together by Miki Meek. I should say there's some curse words in today's program that we have unbeeped for this podcast version of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, it is at our website. Here's Miki.
第一幕，掉进兔子洞。关于Lenny Pozner转变的故事是由Miki Meek制作的。我应该说明一下，今天的节目中有一些脏话，我们在播客版本中没有消音。如果您更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站上找到。下面是Miki。
The first time Lenny became aware of any conspiracy theories about Sandy Hook was about a month after the shooting. He'd been on a media blackout, trying to get through Noah's funeral and taking care of his two young girls. They were also at the elementary school that morning. And one of them was Noah's twin sister. She hid in a separate classroom. But one day, Lenny finally felt ready to go online, read the news, googled his son's name.
Lenny第一次意识到有关桑迪胡克事件的阴谋论是在枪击案发生大约一个月后。他当时正处于媒体封锁状态，试图度过Noah的葬礼并照顾他的两个小女儿。那天早上她们也在那所小学。其中一个是Noah的双胞胎姐姐。她躲在另一间教室里。但有一天，Lenny终于觉得可以上网读读新闻了，于是搜索了他儿子的名字。
Infowars was coming up on search results. The forums.
InfoWars出现在搜索结果中。还有那些论坛。
The forums.
论坛。
Yeah. And it's just completely disgusting.
是的。简直恶心透顶。
In just over 30 days, this whole world had been invented. And one of the central pieces of it involved Lenny's wife. Infowars fans were dissecting this one interview she did on CNN. It was with Anderson Cooper just days after Noah's funeral.
在短短30多天里，整个世界就被编造出来了。其中一个核心部分涉及Lenny的妻子。InfoWars的粉丝们在剖析她接受CNN采访时的那一段。那是她在Noah葬礼几天后接受Anderson Cooper采访时的内容。
What do you want people to know about Noah?
你想让人们了解关于Noah的什么事？
He loved running and playing with his siblings, and he loved bubble baths and fireflies. And he loved eating the inside of Oreo cookies. And he played the video Gangnam Style ad nauseum.
他喜欢和兄弟姐妹们一起奔跑玩耍，喜欢泡泡浴和萤火虫。他喜欢吃奥利奥饼干的夹心。他还不厌其烦地播放《江南Style》。
I understand he used to tell his siblings that he managed a taco factory.
我听说他以前常告诉他的兄弟姐妹们，他经营着一家炸玉米饼工厂。
Yes, that he was going to split his time as an adult between managing a taco factory and being an astronaut.
是的，他说他成年后会把时间分配在经营一家炸玉米饼工厂和当宇航员之间。
The comments online were gross and flimsy. Why didn't she sound sadder? Why would she put on lipstick if she was really grieving? And wasn't she too old to be the mom of a six-year-old kid? They were convinced that something was up.
网上的评论既粗俗又站不住脚。为什么她听起来不够悲伤？如果她真的在悲伤，为什么还要涂口红？她作为一个六岁孩子的母亲是不是太老了？他们确信其中有猫腻。
How are you holding up? I mean--
你还好吗？我的意思是——
Most of the time, I'm kind of numb. I think every mom out there can relate to the fact of how long it takes to create a baby. Those nine months that you watch every ultrasound, and every heartbeat. And it takes nine months to create a human being, and it takes seconds for an AR-15 to take that away from the surface of this earth.
大多数时候，我有点麻木。我想每一位母亲都能体会到孕育一个婴儿需要多长时间。那九个月里，你看着每一次超声波，每一次心跳。创造一个人需要九个月，而AR-15只需几秒钟就能把他从地球表面抹去。
This reference to guns was another aha moment for conspiracy theorists. Some of them started digging into Veronique's life, looked up her maiden name, and then said, hey, look at this. There's a Swiss diplomat who has her exact same name. And even fishier, this diplomat once went to an arms control summit at the United Nations.
这种对枪支的提及是阴谋论者的另一个“啊哈时刻”。他们中的一些人开始挖掘Veronique的生活，查她的娘家姓，然后说，嘿，看这个。有个瑞士外交官跟她同名。更可疑的是，这位外交官曾参加过联合国的军备控制峰会。
So maybe they're the same person. Maybe she's one of those elite globalists trying to make guns look bad, so President Obama can repeal the Second Amendment. Suddenly, every real sentiment Veronique shared about Noah was getting reinterpreted as lines from a sinister script.
所以也许她们是同一个人。也许她是那些试图让枪支看起来很糟糕的精英全球主义者之一，这样奥巴马总统就可以废除第二修正案。突然间，Veronique分享的关于Noah的每一个真实感受都被重新解读为邪恶剧本中的台词。
They were here, and they mattered. They all have families. And they mattered.
他们曾经在这里，他们很重要。他们都有家人。他们很重要。
And the kicker that cinched it for these conspiracy theorists? Anderson Cooper's nose. There's this moment when the tip of his nose disappears because of a digital glitch in the video-- what CNN says was normal interference that happens with a live satellite feed. It's just a couple seconds, but hoaxers wouldn't let it go.
而让这些阴谋论者确信这一点的原因是什么？Anderson Cooper的鼻子。视频中有一个时刻，因为数字故障，他的鼻尖消失了——CNN称这在直播卫星信号中是常有的正常干扰。只有几秒钟，但骗子们不肯放过它。
They said that it's a green screen, or a blue screen, or whatever. So that was a fake interview, and Veronique was a participant of a fake, staged CNN interview. That conspiracy theory was all over YouTube, and it was all over YouTube with Noah's image.
他们说那是绿幕，或者蓝幕，或其他什么东西。所以那是一次虚假的采访，Veronique是那个虚假、策划好的CNN采访的参与者。那个阴谋论遍布YouTube，而且带着Noah的照片到处传播。
I've talked to parents who've lost kids in other mass shootings, and they've all been blindsided by online harassment from conspiracy theorists. The crisis actor claim is so common now these attacks usually start almost immediately after victims are IDed in the media. And parents who go on TV and talk about gun control, like Veronique, they get it the worst.
我采访过在其他大规模枪击事件中失去孩子的父母，他们都曾被阴谋论者的网络骚扰搞得措手不及。危机演员的说法现在太普遍了，这些攻击通常在媒体确定受害者身份后几乎立即开始。而像Veronique那样上电视谈论枪支管制的父母，受到的伤害最深。
Sandy Hook is when this really took off. Families get stuck fending off all this crazy hate by themselves. There just aren't that many resources for them, because law enforcement still hasn't figured out how to deal with most cyber harassment, and the tech companies aren't much help. So most families just try to ignore the conspiracy theorists, and hope they'll eventually go away.
桑迪胡克事件是这一切真正开始的时候。家庭只能独自应付所有这些疯狂的仇恨。他们几乎没有什么资源，因为执法部门还没找到如何处理大多数网络骚扰的方法，而科技公司也帮不上什么忙。所以大多数家庭只是试图无视这些阴谋论者，希望他们最终会消失。
And that's what Lenny did for a while. His life was a wreck. But after about a year and a half, they were still at it, and he couldn't let it go anymore.
这就是Lenny一段时间以来的做法。他的生活一团糟。但大约一年半后，他们依然故我，他再也无法忍受了。
I realized that grieving requires a calmness, and a silence. And all of this material was a distraction for me, and it was noise. And I needed to handle that noise, so that I could have the silence and calm that I needed.
我意识到悲伤需要一种平静，一种沉默。所有这些材料对我来说都是一种干扰，它们是噪音。我需要处理这些噪音，这样我才能拥有我所需要的沉默与平静。
There's this photo I love of Lenny, with his arm wrapped around Noah. He's got a walrus mustache, and he's kneeling on a trampoline with a soft smile. It's spring, and Noah has all this big, brown hair, fat cheeks. He's snuggling his whole body into Lenny's chest. Lenny's got tons of family photos like these, posted them in an online memorial he made for Noah right after he died.
我非常喜欢一张Lenny的照片，他双臂环抱着Noah。他留着海象胡子，跪在蹦床上，带着温柔的微笑。那是春天，Noah留着一头浓密的棕色头发，有着肥嘟嘟的脸颊。他整个人都蜷缩在Lenny的怀里。Lenny有很多这样的家庭照片，他在Noah去世后为他建立的在线纪念馆里发布了这些照片。
The Sandy Hook deniers downloaded them, and repurposed them into cruel memes. Wrote "fake" across Noah's face, took a picture of his headstone and photoshopped under his name, "is not buried here." Photos of his daughters were circulating, too. He couldn't just leave them out there on the web with the trolls.
桑迪胡克否认者下载了这些照片，并把它们重构成残忍的表情包。在Noah的脸上写上“假”，拿走他墓碑的照片，并在他名字下面用Photoshop加上“没有埋在这里”。他女儿的照片也在流传。他不能就这样把它们留在网上任由喷子们摆布。
Lenny got consumed with thinking about how to take control of the situation, how to extract Noah and his family from all this. The internet didn't scare him. It was actually his comfort zone. He ran his own IT business. He was not the kind of guy who sat around and complained about how something didn't work. He was the guy who fixed stuff.
Lenny沉迷于思考如何控制局面，如何将Noah和他的家人从这一切中解救出来。互联网并没有吓倒他。事实上，那是他的舒适区。他经营着自己的IT业务。他不是那种坐着抱怨事情为什么行不通的人。他是那个解决问题的人。
So you need to find what the problem is, and then find what your solution is, and then start getting closer to that solution, step by step. Otherwise the problem is overwhelming, and then you just want someone else to fix it for you.
所以你需要找出问题所在，然后找到解决方案，然后一步步接近那个解决方案。否则问题会让人不知所措，那你只会想让别人替你解决。
Yeah.
是的。
You have to track down where you can make a difference, and get closer to being less broken.
你必须找到你能有所作为的地方，并让自己少受一点伤害。
There was one other thing that made Lenny especially qualified to deal with the conspiracy theorists. He used to enjoy those theories himself. The classic fun ones-- Bigfoot, Loch Ness, Area 51, NASA faking the moon landing.
还有一件事使Lenny特别有资格应付阴谋论者。他自己曾经也很享受这些理论。那些经典的有趣的理论——大脚怪、尼斯湖水怪、51区、NASA伪造登月。
Like, what's the fun of it?
比如，那有什么乐趣？
It's suspending your disbelief. It's like sitting down and watching a science fiction movie, and then looking at the what if. And it's just fun, especially if there's no price to pay in your life, and there's no cost to that way of thinking, then it's just a game.
那是暂停你的怀疑。就像坐下来看一部科幻电影，然后看着“如果……会怎样”。这很有趣，特别是如果你的生活中没有代价，这种思维方式也没有损失，那就只是个游戏。
Sometimes he even listened to Alex Jones in his car. And in fact, just a month after the shootings, when Lenny first saw those things on Alex Jones's website, he tried to reach out. He found a general Infowars email address, and shot him off this message.
有时他甚至在车里听Alex Jones的节目。事实上，就在枪击案发生一个月后，当Lenny第一次在Alex Jones的网站上看到那些东西时，他试图联系他。他找到了一个通用的InfoWars电子邮件地址，发去了这条信息。
"Alex, I'm very disappointed to see how many people are directing more anger at families that lost their children in Newtown, accusing us of being actors. Haven't we had our share of pain and suffering? I used to enjoy listening to your shows. Now I feel that your type of show created these hateful people, and they need to be reeled in!" Exclamation point.
“Alex，我非常失望地看到有这么多人将更多的愤怒指向在纽敦失去孩子的家庭，指责我们是演员。我们受的痛苦和折磨还不够吗？我以前很喜欢听你的节目。现在我觉得你的节目类型制造了这些可恨的人，他们需要被管教！”感叹号。
About an hour later, he heard back from Jones' staff.
大约一小时后，他收到了Jones员工的回复。
And they responded with "We have not supported the crisis actor claim. We insist that it's a true event." On and on.
他们回复说：“我们不支持危机演员的说法。我们坚持认为这是一个真实的事件。”云云。
This wasn't true. Jones did spread the crisis actor theory. It was on his website at the time, and he started talking about it a lot. That CNN interview with Veronique, he talked about it all the time.
这不是真的。Jones确实传播了危机演员的理论。当时这就在他的网站上，他开始频繁谈论它。关于Veronique的那次CNN采访，他一直在谈论。
Folks, we've got video of Anderson Cooper with clear blue screen out there. He's not there in the town square. We've got people clearly coming up and laughing and then doing the fake crying. We've clearly got people where it's actors playing different parts of different people. I've looked at it, and undoubtedly there's a cover-up. There's actors. They're manipulating. They've been caught lying. And they were pre-planning before it, and then rolled out with it.
伙计们，我们有Anderson Cooper在外面使用清晰蓝幕的视频。他不在镇广场上。我们有人们明显走上前去大笑，然后假装哭泣。我们有明显的人在扮演不同角色的不同人物。我看过了，毫无疑问有一个掩盖行为。有演员。他们在操纵。他们被抓到撒谎。他们在这之前就在预谋，然后带着它出场了。
What Lenny wanted was a one-on-one conversation with Jones, but it didn't happen.
Lenny想要的是与Jones进行一对一的对话，但这并没有发生。
There were a few emails after that, asking me to prove that I'm really who I am, and leading on to get me on the show.
在那之后又有几封邮件，要求我证明我的真实身份，并诱导我上节目。
Lenny didn't want that. He's very private and very reserved, a behind the scenes kind of guy. He's careful when he talks. Things like "no comment," "that's off the record," or "do I have to talk about my personal life?" That came up all the time during our interview.
Lenny不想那样。他非常注重隐私且非常矜持，是一个幕后型的人。他说话很谨慎。像“无可奉告”、“那是非公开的”、“我必须谈论我的个人生活吗？”这样的话在我们的采访中一直出现。
One of the ground rules he gave is that I had to run his quotes past him and his lawyer, because he's worried about his own safety, if his words were misconstrued. Also, he's fighting some of the conspiracy theories in court. We agreed to his terms. And in the end, he didn't ask me to edit any of his quotes. But he did request that we remove one personal detail, and we did.
他提出的基本规则之一是我必须将他的引语发给他和他的律师审阅，因为如果他的话被曲解，他担心自己的人身安全。此外，他还在法庭上对抗一些阴谋论。我们同意了他的条款。最后，他没有要求我修改他的任何引语。但他确实要求我们删除一个个人细节，我们照做了。
Now, a year and a half after he reached out to Alex Jones, he decided to try a new tactic. He'd go directly to Jones his followers and the other Sandy Hook conspiracy theorists.
现在，在他联系Alex Jones一年半后，他决定尝试一种新的策略。他要直接针对Jones的追随者和其他桑迪胡克阴谋论者。
I think his approach was, "I'm going to make them see the light."
我想他的策略是，“我要让他们看到真相。”
This is Veronique. She and Lenny were separated when the shooting happened, but were still very much in each other's lives. They decided to start releasing documents about Noah. Report cards, school photos.
这是Veronique。枪击发生时她和Lenny分居，但仍非常密切地参与彼此的生活。他们决定开始发布关于Noah的文件。成绩单、学校照片。
He even disclosed Noah's death certificate, which was a difficult decision that we made, but figured, after a while of providing this hard copy convincing evidence that reason would prevail, and they would say, "oh, OK, yeah, you've made your point. I'm going to come around."
他甚至公开了Noah的死亡证明，这是我们做出的一个艰难决定，但心想，在提供这些确凿的证据一段时间后，理性会占上风，他们会说，“哦，好的，是的，你说的有道理。我会回心转意。”
Lenny also decided he'd answer anyone's questions. He wanted to join this notorious Facebook group called "Sandy Hook Hoax." It's where a lot of the deniers were congregating and sharing theories. The cover photo on their page looked like it came straight out of a horror movie. A corpse-like girl with a "keep quiet" finger in front of her mouth. The administrator of the Facebook group immediately let him in.
Lenny还决定回答任何人的问题。他想加入那个臭名昭著的Facebook群组“桑迪胡克骗局”。这是很多否认者聚集并分享理论的地方。他们页面上的封面照片看起来像是直接从恐怖电影里出来的。一个僵尸般的女孩，手指放在嘴前做“保持安静”的手势。Facebook群组的管理员立刻让他进去了。
Do you identify yourself as like, "I am a father?"
你是否表明自己的身份，比如“我是一个父亲？”
They knew who I was. They knew who I was instantly, yeah.
他们知道我是谁。他们立刻就知道了，是的。
To me, it seems so crazy to even go there. Like, this doesn't exactly sound like a group of people who'd want to listen to you.
对我来说，甚至去那里似乎都很疯狂。比如，这听起来并不像是一群你想对他们说话的人。
People who are conspiracy-minded see these tragedies unfold on the internet or on television. They still feel separate from these events. And I considered that bridging that gap could be an important step.
有阴谋心态的人在互联网或电视上看到这些悲剧发生。他们仍然觉得与这些事件无关。我认为弥合这一鸿沟可能是一个重要的步骤。
I can add a human element to this.
我可以给这件事增加一个人性因素。
That's right. That's right. And so here I am. I'm the person. So let let's see what happens.
没错。没错。所以我就在这儿。我就是那个人。所以让我们看看会发生什么。
The questions started pouring in.
问题开始接踵而至。
"Why weren't these children rushed to hospitals?" "Why wasn't anything done?" "Why aren't you suing the EMTs?" Or "why aren't you doing this?" "Why wasn't a rescue helicopter called from Hartford?" And I started to recognize some of the patterns that were there.
“为什么这些孩子没有被送往医院？”“为什么什么都没做？”“你为什么不起诉急救人员？”或者“你为什么不这样做？”“为什么没有从哈特福德调来救援直升机？”我开始识别出那里的一些模式。
There were the people you'd expect in a conspiracy group-- anti-gun control people, anti-government people, but also parents.
那里有你在阴谋论组织中会预料到的人——反枪支管制的人、反政府的人，但也有父母。
They were young parents with small children, and they just couldn't wrap their minds around the reality that an adult can look at children in their eyes, and pump bullets into their head. They just can't deal with that.
他们是带着小孩的年轻父母，他们无法理解这样一个现实：一个成年人可以看着孩子的眼睛，把子弹射进他们的头里。他们只是无法接受这一点。
The conversation on this Facebook group quickly got ugly and abusive. Some of the members started using anti-Semitic slurs. Lenny was trying everything to keep up a rapport with them, even told them "I listen to Alex Jones in my car. I used to argue with people about 9/11 being an inside job. I entertained that we didn't go to the moon." But it didn't work. So he started blocking people and fighting back. This got him booted from the group.
这个Facebook群组上的对话很快变得丑陋且具有攻击性。一些成员开始使用反犹太主义的诋毁词。Lenny尝试了一切来保持与他们的融洽关系，甚至告诉他们“我在车里听Alex Jones的节目。我以前常和别人争论‘9·11’是内部工作。我还怀疑过我们没有登月。”但这没用。所以他开始屏蔽并回击。这导致他被踢出了群组。
What's remarkable is just how up for this whole fight he was. When a bunch of people kept private messaging him, Lenny thought, "you know what? I'll just start my own Facebook group." He called it "Conspiracy Theorists Anonymous." This name was meant as a joke. He has a dry sense of humor.
引人注目的是他应对整场战斗的劲头。当一群人不断给他发私人信息时，Lenny想，“你知道吗？我不如自己建一个Facebook群组。”他把它命名为“阴谋论者匿名会”。这个名字是开个玩笑。他有一种冷幽默感。
Anyway, he made some progress with people, the people who weren't full blown deniers, who actually wanted help parsing out the truth of what really happened. But they dropped away once they got answers. And pretty soon, the only ones left were just dark, sadistic trolls coming in to entertain themselves.
不管怎样，他在人们身上取得了一些进展，那些不是彻头彻尾的否认者，确实想寻求帮助来解析到底发生了什么的人。但当他们得到答案后就离开了。很快，剩下的只有黑暗、虐待狂般的喷子，他们进来是为了取乐。
One of Lenny's worst trolls was a guy named Wolfgang Halbig. That's his real name, by the way. He's a retired school security expert in Florida, who's probably the number one Newtown hoaxer in the world. This guy traveled to Newtown, appeared as an expert on Alex Jones's show. He's even called for Newtown parents to exhume the bodies of their children to prove that they're dead.
Lenny最糟糕的喷子之一是一个叫Wolfgang Halbig的人。顺便说一句，这是他的真名。他是一位佛罗里达州退休的学校安全专家，可能是世界上头号纽敦骗局制造者。这家伙去过纽敦，作为专家出现在Alex Jones的节目中。他甚至呼吁纽敦的父母开棺验尸，以证明他们的孩子已经死了。
Halbig ordered a background check on Lenny, then sent it out in an email to lots of people. It was almost 100 pages, listing everything from his social security number and phone number to almost every address he'd ever lived at with photos. Names of his relatives were included too.
Halbig下令对Lenny进行背景调查，然后通过电子邮件发送给很多人。那份调查报告有近100页，列出了他从社会保险号和电话号码到他曾经住过的几乎每个地址及照片的一切信息。他亲戚的名字也包含在内。
The online harassment had become so intense that Lenny and Veronique, and their two girls, went into hiding. They moved into separate high security gated communities. But Lenny's address kept getting exposed, and hoaxers started posting videos of where he lived.
网络骚扰变得如此强烈，以至于Lenny和Veronique以及他们的两个女儿被迫隐姓埋名。他们搬进了独立的高安全性封闭社区。但Lenny的地址不断被曝光，骗子们开始发布他住处的视频。
One apartment that I had moved into-- I had only lived there, I think, for a month-- and I got a call from a particular hoaxer who happens to be in prison now for attempted murder. And he called me up and was acting like a smart ass, and then read me my social security number, and then read me my address, where I had just moved into. And I said, well, you know what? I don't like this apartment that much, anyway. And I moved shortly after that.
有一套我搬进去的公寓——我想我才住了一个月——我就接到了一个骗子的电话，那家伙现在因为谋杀未遂在监狱里。他打电话给我，表现得像个自作聪明的人，然后念出了我的社会保险号，然后念出了我刚搬进去的地址。我说，好吧，你知道吗？我本来就不太喜欢这套公寓。然后不久我就搬走了。
To try and throw the hoaxers off, Lenny started putting utility bills in different names and got multiple PO boxes all over the place. All this forced Lenny into a new battle strategy. If they were going to expose him, he'd do the same to them. He wrote newspaper op-eds calling out Halbig and the others by name. And when these hoaxers posted his new addresses online, he did the same to them. He also made it so that if you googled their names, the first thing anyone would see was all the Sandy Hook garbage they'd created.
为了试图迷惑这些骗子，Lenny开始用不同的名字缴纳水电费，并到处设立了多个邮政信箱。这一切迫使Lenny采取了一种新的战斗策略。如果他们要曝光他，他也会以其人之道还治其人之身。他写报纸专栏点名Halbig和其他人。当这些骗子在网上发布他的新地址时，他也对他们做了同样的事。他还做到了这一点：如果你搜索他们的名字，任何人看到的第一件事就是他们制造的所有关于桑迪胡克的垃圾。
And Lenny being Lenny, decided to write a biography about Wolfgang Halbig's life called "The Hoax of a Lifetime." He released it as an e-book. Lenny became the one who knocks. He calls this troll wrestling. It's like trolling the trolls. He gets both energized and sheepish when talking about it. He insists, sometimes the only way to fight hardcore hoaxers is to turn the tables on them. And it worked on some of them, freaked them out.
而身为Lenny的Lenny，决定写一本关于Wolfgang Halbig生平的传记，书名叫《终身的骗局》。他将其作为电子书发布。Lenny成了那个“敲门的人”。他称这为“喷子摔跤”。这就像是在用喷子对付喷子。谈到这一点时，他既充满活力又有点羞怯。他坚持认为，有时对抗铁杆骗子的唯一方法就是以牙还牙。这对他们中的一些人奏效了，吓坏了他们。
Still, Lenny was just one guy. And every day, new mountains of content about Noah were showing up online. His crusade was a lonely one. The hoaxers seemed so dangerous, most of the other Newtown parents wanted to stay as far away as possible from them.
尽管如此，Lenny只是一个人。每天，网上都会出现关于Noah的新内容。他的远征是孤独的。这些骗子看起来太危险了，大多数其他纽敦父母都想尽可能远离他们。
In my darker moments, the conspiracy part of me would return and ask myself, am I the only one that lost a child? Why am I the only one fighting back? I mean, what the hell is going on? I mean, people were trampling all over other people's children's memories, and those children no longer had a voice to defend themselves. And people were just silent about it.
在我比较黑暗的时刻，我内心阴谋论的那一部分会回来问自己，我是唯一失去孩子的人吗？为什么我是唯一一个反击的人？我的意思是，这到底是怎么回事？我的意思是，人们在践踏其他人的孩子的记忆，而那些孩子不再有声音来为自己辩护。而人们对此保持沉默。
But while Lenny was escalating his tactics, so was the other side. Around the second anniversary of Sandy Hook, a small group of conspiracy theorists made an almost three hour movie on YouTube, questioning the shooting. They described themselves as independent journalists and researchers, but their backgrounds were totally random. They included a magician, the owner of a moving company, a guy who'd been arrested for stabbing someone five times, and a stay-at-home dad.
但当Lenny升级他的策略时，对方也在升级。在桑迪胡克两周年纪念日左右，一小群阴谋论者在YouTube上制作了一部近三小时的电影，质疑这次枪击事件。他们自称为独立记者和研究人员，但他们的背景完全是随机的。其中包括一名魔术师、一家搬家公司的老板、一个曾因捅人五刀而被捕的家伙，以及一名全职爸爸。
I just had an idea that I wanted to be an underground filmmaker myself.
我只是有个想法，我想自己成为一名地下电影制片人。
This is Doug Maguire. He says he met this group online, on YouTube, and got brought in at the end to help polish the movie. It felt exciting. At the time, Doug was a struggling filmmaker in Los Angeles. Occasionally did some stunt work. He got into conspiracy theories the way lots of people do-- watching them on YouTube. Like Lenny, he loved the ones about Bigfoot and UFOs. But then he went to look up news about Sandy Hook, and YouTube's recommendation system started suggesting hoax videos.
这是Doug Maguire。他说他在网上、在YouTube上遇到了这个组织，并被拉进去帮助润色这部电影。这感觉很令人兴奋。当时，Doug在洛杉矶是一名苦苦挣扎的电影制片人。偶尔做一些特技工作。他像许多人一样迷上了阴谋论——通过YouTube观看它们。像Lenny一样，他喜欢关于大脚怪和不明飞行物的理论。但后来他去查询关于桑迪胡克的新闻，YouTube的推荐系统开始向他推荐骗局视频。
He didn't believe the theory that the kids were actors. He thought children died, but he felt pretty sure there was some other kind of cover up going on, maybe one with the mafia.
他不相信孩子们是演员的说法。他认为孩子们确实死了，但他觉得肯定还有其他某种掩盖行动，也许是和黑手党有关的。
And where did you get that information? Like, where did you come up with this idea of a mob? Had you read this somewhere?
你是从哪里得到这些信息的？比如，你是怎么想出黑帮这个主意的？你是在哪里读到的吗？
No, it was-- you know, because I make movies. So I think I have an active imagination.
不，那是——你知道，因为我制作电影。所以我认为我有活跃的想象力。
I'm confused. What was your thinking?
我糊涂了。你的想法是什么？
A family had done someone wrong. Like, let's say the movie Goodfellas, OK? Henry Hill is hiding out in a little village.
一个家庭对某人做了坏事。比如，就说《好家伙》这部电影吧，好吗？Henry Hill躲在一个小村庄里。
He also mentioned Kindergarten Cop. When they released their film, they uploaded it to a bunch of different accounts, on places like YouTube, Vimeo, Dailymotion. Pretty soon, it was showing up everywhere. To combat this, Lenny had to change tactics one final time. No more talking to hoaxers one-on-one. Now the thing he'd focus on was content removal, scrubbing their stuff off the internet.
他还提到了《幼儿园警探》。当他们发行电影时，他们将其上传到许多不同的账户上，在YouTube、Vimeo、Dailymotion等地。很快，它到处都在出现。为了对抗这一点，Lenny不得不最后一次改变策略。不再与骗子一对一地交谈。现在他要关注的是内容删除，把他们的东西从互联网上清除掉。
He decided he was going to get every single copy of the movie taken down, which wasn't going to be easy. He couldn't just write into YouTube and say, "hey, this video is full of lies." That wasn't going to be enough. The internet is full of lies. He needed something else. And he realized he had it.
他决定要把电影的每一份拷贝都下架，这并不容易。他不能只是给YouTube写信说，“嘿，这个视频全是谎言。”那是不够的。互联网上到处都是谎言。他需要别的东西。而他意识到他有。
These conspiracy theorists had used photos and videos of him and Noah and Veronique. Those were his property, making this movie a copyright violation. The stolen images were now a useful weapon. Lenny tracked down every place where this video was posted. And you've probably seen this. There's a little button you can click on to report stuff. So that's what he did for hours every day. And success. Sort of. The hoaxers kept reposting and moving the video onto other sites.
这些阴谋论者使用了他和Noah还有Veronique的照片和视频。那是他的财产，这使得这部电影构成版权侵权。被窃取的图像现在是一个有用的武器。Lenny追踪了发布这个视频的每一个地方。你可能见过这个。有一个小按钮可以点击来举报东西。所以这就是他每天花几小时做的事情。成功了。某种程度上。骗子们不断转发并将视频移动到其他网站上。
You know, the crazies are not running the asylum. It's the platforms who are allowing this to go on. So that solidifies it for me that we have to just remove all of this garbage, and that's all we need to do.
你知道，疯子们并没有在经营精神病院。是那些允许这一切发生的平台。所以这对我来说更坚定了这一点：我们必须删除所有这些垃圾，而这就是我们需要做的全部。
But this, of course, pissed off a lot of hoaxers.
但这当然激怒了许多骗子。
We don't know what's going on. We just know it doesn't look right.
我们不知道发生了什么。我们只知道它看起来不对劲。
Alex Jones. He was stumped. Lenny had successfully forced the Infowars site to remove pictures of Noah using copyright.
Alex Jones。他被难住了。Lenny已成功利用版权迫使InfoWars网站删除了Noah的照片。
So frustrating. This is amazing. The claimant is Lenny Pozner. They think because they can hold out some little kids and say, we're shutting peoples' websites down because they're belittling the memory of these children. No, we're not. But even if we were, you couldn't violate our first amendment, because that's what it's there for. And if you take our rights, you take everybody's rights.
太令人沮丧了。这太惊人了。原告是Lenny Pozner。他们认为因为他们可以举着一些小孩子，说我们要关闭人们的网站，因为他们在贬低这些孩子的记忆。不，我们没有。但即使我们有，你也不能违反我们的第一修正案，因为这就是它存在的原因。如果你剥夺了我们的权利，你就剥夺了所有人的权利。
And Jones put one of the guys who worked on the movie on the air. His name is Brian. He's from Alabama.
Jones把参与制作电影的一个家伙带上了节目。他叫Brian。他来自阿拉巴马州。
What do you think of us being censored? What's been happening to you?
你对我们被审查有什么看法？你经历了什么？
I can tell you lots about Lenny. This man is something that you've never seen before. He's got a group of trolls.
我可以告诉你很多关于Lenny的事情。这个人是你从未见过的。他有一群喷子。
I mean, they're trying to shut us down, when we're just investigating it and looking at all sides, it must be horrible for folks out there that vehemently think this is staged. So just specifically, what have you gone through?
我的意思是，当我们只是在调查它并从各个角度看待它时，他们却试图关闭我们，这对那些坚决认为这是演戏的人来说一定很糟糕。所以具体来说，你经历了什么？
I can't even put up a video showing that he has put up a copyright strike against me without him copywriting striking that. These people are vile. And Lenny, if you're listening, your day is coming, my friend. It is coming.
我甚至不能发布一个视频来展示他对我有版权打击，而他不对此进行版权打击。这些人很卑鄙。Lenny，如果你在听，你的日子到了，我的朋友。它到了。
Wow. I mean, this sounds like a war is going on. I think they made a major mistake involving us.
哇。我的意思是，这听起来像是一场战争正在进行。我认为他们招惹我们犯了大错。
Oh, I totally agree. They don't know what they bit off. Go after him, Alex. Crush him.
哦，我完全同意。他们不知道他们咬了什么。去对付他，Alex。粉碎他。
In this video on YouTube, Jones showed his fans-- he had millions of them-- Lenny's email, the city he lived in, and the address he picked up his mail. Even held up some satellite shots from Google Earth. Lenny got this video taken down too, flagging it for privacy violations. But it didn't matter. The hoaxers had taken on a mob mentality, pursuing and harassing Lenny. This is an Infowars fan named Lucy Richards, who left multiple death threats on Lenny's phone.
在这个YouTube视频中，Jones向他的粉丝——他有数百万粉丝——展示了Lenny的电子邮件、他居住的城市以及他取件的地址。甚至还举出了一些来自谷歌地球的卫星镜头。Lenny也把这个视频下架了，因为隐私违规标记了它。但这没用。骗子们已经形成了一种暴民心态，追求并骚扰Lenny。这是一个叫Lucy Richards的InfoWars粉丝，她在Lenny的电话里留下了多次死亡威胁。
Did you hide your imaginary son in an attic? Are you still fucking him, you fucking Jew bastard? You're gonna die. You're gonna rot in hell. Death is coming to you real soon, and there's nothing you can do about it. So you're just gonna have to take it, OK? Jew bastard. Look behind you. Death is coming to you real soon.
你把你的虚构儿子藏在阁楼里了吗？你还在强奸他吗，你这个操蛋的犹太混蛋？你会死的。你会在地狱里腐烂。死亡很快就会降临到你身上，你什么也做不了。所以你只能承受，好吗？犹太混蛋。看你身后。死亡很快就会降临到你身上。
She said, "Look behind you. Death is coming to you real soon." Lenny was already living in hiding. He'd moved multiple times by then, because hoaxers kept tracking down his address. But now the chances that a hoaxer might show up at his door and kill him suddenly felt much higher. His kids were living with him half the week, and he worried about them. At the same time, he didn't consider stopping. He didn't think it would make them safer.
她说，“看你身后。死亡很快就会降临到你身上。”Lenny当时已经在躲藏了。在那之前他已经搬了好几次家，因为骗子们不断追踪他的地址。但现在一个骗子可能出现在门口杀他的可能性感觉突然高得多了。他的孩子半周和他住在一起，他很为她们担心。与此同时，他没考虑停止。他不认为这会使她们更安全。
That's one of the misconceptions that exist, that people think that I am only targeted because of challenging the content. And that's not the case. I took the action because I was being targeted. So if my address was published all over the internet, my photo was published all over the internet, and my living children's photos are published online, that's existed before I did anything. I didn't cause the targeting. It was already there. I was minimizing the targeting.
这是存在的误解之一，人们认为我受到针对只是因为质疑了内容。事实并非如此。我采取行动是因为我受到了针对。所以如果我的地址被发布在整个互联网上，我的照片被发布在整个互联网上，我活着孩子的照片被发布在网上，那是发生在我做任何事情之前就存在的。我没有造成针对。它已经在那里了。我是在最小化针对。
He posted receipts for firearms. I'd asked if he actually bought them, and he wouldn't give me an answer. Amidst all this, Lenny kept up his daily ritual. He'd wake up, make coffee, and then sit in front of his computer for hours, flagging content, trying to systematically erase Noah from the Sandy Hook hoax story. There was a lot of stuff he couldn't invoke copyright law for, like the death threats and harassment. That was much harder to get taken down.
他张贴了枪支收据。我问他是否真的买了它们，他没有给我答案。在这一切之中，Lenny继续他每天的仪式。他起床，煮咖啡，然后坐在电脑前几个小时，标记内容，试图系统地将Noah从桑迪胡克骗局的故事中抹去。有很多东西他不能诉诸版权法，比如死亡威胁和骚扰。那些要下架要困难得多。
The tech companies were wary of becoming arbiters of truth, making decisions about what its users could and couldn't say. But Lenny, in his usual methodical fashion, kept chipping away. On YouTube, he kept a scorecard. Once he nailed someone with three copyright strikes, YouTube would remove their accounts. He killed thousands of videos this way. The hoaxers called this "getting Poznered." He'd become a hashtag.
科技公司对成为真理的仲裁者感到谨慎，对用户可以和不可以说什么做出决定。但Lenny以他一贯条理分明的方式，不断挖掘。在YouTube上，他保留了一张记分卡。一旦他用三次版权打击抓住某人，YouTube就会删除他们的账户。他用这种方式杀死了成千上万个视频。骗子们称这为“被Pozner化”。他成了标签。
Then he and Veronique helped get a professor in Florida, named James Tracy, fired. This guy had harassed them for years, and kept using Noah's image to promote his conspiracy theories. He's also the one who helped popularize the conspiracy term "crisis actor" on his blog right after the shooting.
然后他和Veronique帮助佛罗里达州一位名叫James Tracy的教授被解雇。这家伙骚扰了他们多年，并一直使用Noah的照片来推销他的阴谋论。他也是枪击案后在他博客上推广阴谋论术语“危机演员”的人。
And that woman who was leaving death threats, Lucy Richards? Lenny reported her to the police, and they arrested her. She was sentenced to five months in jail. The judge rebuked her for going after Lenny, saying, quote, "This is a reality, and there is no fiction. There are no alternative facts." He barred her from Infowars and other conspiracy websites as one of the conditions of her parole.
还有那个留下死亡威胁的女人Lucy Richards？Lenny向警方举报了她，他们逮捕了她。她被判入狱五个月。法官斥责她针对Lenny，引用道：“这是一个现实，没有虚构。没有替代事实。”他禁止她访问InfoWars和其他阴谋论网站，作为她假释条件之一。
One surprising thing that happened over the years is that some of the hoaxers who used to harass Lenny flipped to his side. There were dozens of them. Lenny says these were people who came to him only after they changed their own minds, not people he tried to convert. He says that never works. It's a waste of time. Some of them became disenchanted when they saw Sandy Hook hoaxers who were more interested in photo shopping evidence and getting online followers than tracking down the truth.
多年来发生的一件令人惊讶的事情是，一些曾经骚扰Lenny的骗子翻转到了他这一边。有几十个。Lenny说这些人是在改变主意后才来到他身边的，而不是他试图转化的人。他说那从来不起作用。那是浪费时间。他们中的一些人在看到桑迪胡克骗局制造者对Photoshop证据和获取网络追随者的兴趣超过追踪真相时，感到幻灭。
One of them was Doug, who worked on that hoaxer movie about Sandy Hook. In 2016, he found a phone number for Lenny and left a voicemail.
其中一个是Doug，他参与了那部关于桑迪胡克的骗局电影。2016年，他找到了Lenny的电话号码并留下了语音邮件。
"Hey, Lenny Pozner, this is dickhead Doug Maguire. If you ever need me, if you ever want to get a hold of me and learn about what all these people are up to, here's my number."
“嘿，Lenny Pozner，这是混蛋Doug Maguire。如果你需要我，如果你想联系我并了解这些人都在干什么，这是我的号码。”
Did you apologize in that message?
你在那条信息里道歉了吗？
I don't believe I did.
我不相信我道歉了。
Not surprisingly, Lenny didn't return his call. Doug was reaching out to Lenny because the hoaxers had turned on him, too. He says he started feuding with some of them after he made a video exposing a Christian YouTuber who was making money off false, outrageous claims. All of his social media accounts then got hacked.
不出所料，Lenny没有回他的电话。Doug联系Lenny是因为骗子们也转而针对他了。他说，在他制作了一个揭露一名靠虚假、令人发指的说法赚钱的基督教YouTuber的视频后，他开始与他们中的一些人发生争执。他所有的社交媒体账户随后都被黑了。
Lenny was the only person he could think of who knew how to fight back. He wanted advice. So he tried him again, and got through. He told Lenny that it felt like he'd been sort of brainwashed. That he'd been on a roller coaster ride, that he wanted to switch sides. Lenny had started a nonprofit called The HONR Network, where volunteers help families from mass tragedies fight digital harassment. So Doug began helping him scrub content.
Lenny是他能想到的唯一知道如何反击的人。他想要建议。所以他再次尝试，并成功接通了。他告诉Lenny感觉自己像是被洗脑了。说他一直在坐过山车，他想换边。Lenny创办了一个叫HONR Network的非营利组织，志愿者们帮助大悲剧受害家庭对抗数字骚扰。所以Doug开始帮助他清除内容。
When you were doing it, did you feel like you were doing penance?
当你在做的时候，你觉得你在赎罪吗？
Yeah. Yeah, and my heart is very heavy for this.
是的。是的，我为此感到沉重。
Were you surprised at how quickly Lenny let you in?
你对Lenny让你加入的速度感到惊讶吗？
Yeah, and I still am. The fact that he even is giving me a chance, I'm very humbled. I tell him I love him. I tell him that he's like my mentor. Sometimes, I call him "boss," and he says, "don't call me boss."
是的，现在也是。他甚至给我机会这一事实，我感到非常谦卑。我告诉他我爱他。我告诉他他就像我的导师。有时，我叫他“老板”，他说，“别叫我老板。”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Have you you apologized to other families at Sandy Hook?
你向桑迪胡克的其他家庭道歉了吗？
No. I think just to try to call up one of these families that-- they don't need to hear from some kind of a YouTuber guy in Los Angeles. I think, one day-- I am very sorry. Very sorry for any problems to any victims.
没有。我认为试图给这些家庭中的任何一个打电话——他们不需要从洛杉矶的某个YouTuber那里听到什么。我想，有一天——我非常抱歉。对任何受害者造成的任何问题都非常抱歉。
Doug is now one of Lenny's most devoted volunteers. Lenny's got more than 100 people helping him out at any given time. But the burnout rate is high because the work is so intense. And hoaxers harass volunteers like Doug all the time for helping Lenny.
Doug现在是Lenny最忠诚的志愿者之一。Lenny随时都有100多人帮助他。但倦怠率很高，因为工作太紧张了。而且骗子们一直因为Doug帮助Lenny而骚扰他。
When Lenny Googles Noah's name now, he no longer gets page after page of hoaxer content. A lot of it is gone now. Instead, the first hits that come up are news articles about Lenny's fight to make the tech companies more accountable. For years, he's been criticizing them in the press for not doing more to protect families of mass tragedies from online abuse.
当Lenny现在谷歌Noah的名字时，他不再得到一页又一页的骗局内容。现在很多都不见了。相反，出现的第一条是关于Lenny为使科技公司承担更多责任而进行斗争的新闻文章。多年来，他一直批评他们在媒体上，因为没有采取更多措施保护大悲剧家庭免受网络暴力。
Last summer, he and Veronique called out Mark Zuckerberg in an open letter in The Guardian. They wrote, quote "you, arguably the most powerful man on the planet, have deemed that the attacks on us are immaterial, that providing assistance in removing threats is too cumbersome, and that our lives are less important than providing a safe haven for hate."
去年夏天，他和Veronique在《卫报》的一封公开信中点名Mark Zuckerberg。他们写道，引用道：“你，可以说地球上最有权势的人，认为对我们的攻击无关紧要，提供帮助删除威胁太麻烦，我们的生活不如为仇恨提供避风港重要。”
Shortly after, Facebook reached out to Lenny. He started working with their content moderators and policymakers, and says their response times are now much faster. He also helped turn up the heat on Alex Jones. Last spring, he and Veronique and another dad from Newtown filed defamation lawsuits against him. Other parents followed with their own suit.
不久之后，Facebook联系了Lenny。他开始与他们的内容版主和决策者合作，并表示他们的响应时间现在快多了。他还帮助给Alex Jones施压。去年春天，他和Veronique以及纽敦的另一位父亲对他提起了诽谤诉讼。其他父母也跟着提起了自己的诉讼。
A few months later, Apple started removing Jones's material from iTunes, saying they would not, quote, tolerate hate speech. Facebook, Google, and Spotify then followed suit. YouTube killed his channel completely, but you can still find his videos on the platform. And Twitter was one of the last to take action against Jones and Infowars. The New York Times reported that getting deplatformed cut his online audience nearly in half.
几个月后，苹果开始从iTunes中删除Jones的材料，称他们不会，引用道，容忍仇恨言论。Facebook、谷歌和Spotify随后效仿。《纽约时报》报道称，被剥夺平台削减了他的网络受众近一半。
I met up with Lenny at his place recently. He lives in a gated high security residence. He was filing copyright and harassment reports to places like Instagram, Pinterest, Reddit, Vimeo, and Twitter. He says Twitter is his biggest headache right now. There's content about Noah he still can't get down, and he gets personally attacked there all the time.
我最近在Lenny的住处和他见面。他住在一个封闭的高安全住所里。他正在向Instagram、Pinterest、Reddit、Vimeo和Twitter等地方提交版权和骚扰报告。他说Twitter是他现在最大的头痛。关于Noah的内容他仍然无法删除，而且他一直在那里受到个人攻击。
Do you feel like you've jumped in this rabbit hole that is never going to end?
你觉得你掉进了这个永远不会结束的兔子洞吗？
I don't think I jumped in. I think I just got pulled in.
我不认为我跳了进去。我想我只是被拉进去了。
You're just constantly subjecting yourself to just so much hateful material.
你一直在让自己承受这么多的仇恨材料。
Just like throwing trash out. Once it's gone, it feels really good. It really does.
就像倒垃圾一样。一旦它消失了，感觉真的很好。真的。
This is what victory looks like, taking the trash out every day. He recently spotted one of the hoaxers who's been after him. Turns out, the person lives nearby. Lenny's about to have to move again. This will be the eighth time.
这就是胜利的样子，每天倒垃圾。他最近发现了追逐他的骗子之一。结果那个人就住在附近。Lenny又要搬家了。这将是第八次。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, how Alex Jones became Alex Jones, or not. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Miki Meek是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，Alex Jones是如何成为Alex Jones的，或者没有成为。请稍候，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Beware the Jabberwock. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2. Alex in Wonderland. So one of the occasional contributors to our program, Jon Ronson, actually got to know Alex Jones personally years ago, long before Alex Jones became the most notorious conspiracy theorist in the country.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，当心Jabberwock。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕。仙境中的Alex。所以我们节目的偶尔贡献者Jon Ronson，实际上多年前就私下认识了Alex Jones，远在Alex Jones成为该国最臭名昭著的阴谋论者之前。
They met doing a story where, together, they snuck into a summertime enclave of the rich and powerful called Bohemian Grove. They each did their own stories about it. Jon thought it was pretty harmless, maybe a little silly. Alex Jones thought it was much more sinister.
他们见面做了一个故事，一起溜进了一个叫波西米亚丛林的有钱有势者的夏季飞地。他们每个人都做了关于它的故事。Jon认为这相当无害，也许有点傻。Alex Jones认为它更邪恶。
Now and then over the years, they would touch base. Then in 2016, Jon met somebody in Alex's orbit. And that is where this story begins.
多年来偶尔，他们会保持联系。然后在2016年，Jon遇到了Alex身边的人。而这就是这个故事开始的地方。
The man's name was Josh Owens, and in October 2016 he started sending me cryptic texts about his boss. "A lot of times, I'm conflicted with what I'm seeing. Anyway, I won't get into that." His boss was Alex Jones. Josh worked for him as a cameraman and a field producer. We exchanged more texts, and then we arranged to meet in a hotel lobby in Washington, DC.
那个人的名字是Josh Owens，2016年10月他开始给我发送关于他老板的神秘短信。“很多时候，我对所看到的感到矛盾。不管怎样，我不想深入谈论那个。”他的老板是Alex Jones。Josh作为摄像师和现场制作人为他工作。我们交换了更多短信，然后安排在华盛顿特区的一家酒店大堂见面。
And here he was, walking in from the street, and waving shyly. I was struck by how nervous he looked. He had traveled here to tell me secrets about Alex. And the reason he chose me was because I have known Alex Jones for so long. When I first met and wrote about him 20 years ago, he broadcast Infowars down an ISDN line from a child's bedroom in his house, which was covered in choo choo train wallpaper.
他就在这里，从街上走进来，羞怯地挥手。他看起来有多紧张让我印象深刻。他来这里是为了告诉我关于Alex的秘密。而他选择我的原因是，我认识Alex Jones太久了。当我20年前第一次见面并写关于他时，他通过ISDN线路从他房子里的儿童卧室广播InfoWars，那里贴满了火车墙纸。
Back then, the whole operation was him, his producer Mike, and his webmaster executive producer girlfriend Kelly, also known as Violet.
当时，整个行动是他，他的制作人Mike，还有他的网站管理员执行制作人女友Kelly，也被称为Violet。
Well, Alex at 26-years-old is now syndicated to over 40 commercial markets. So he's huge, not to mention that he's on short wave and the internet. He's been number one on AOL numerous times. Alex is a sensation, because he's young, he's vibrant, and so many people are getting involved with this movement through what Alex does.
嗯，26岁的Alex现在已联合到40多个商业市场。所以他很大，更不用说他在短波和互联网上了。他多次在AOL上排名第一。Alex是个轰动，因为他年轻、充满活力，而且许多人通过Alex所做的事情参与到了这个运动中。
This is tape I recorded back in 1999. Violet would eventually become Alex's wife, and then years later, his ex-wife in an extremely acrimonious divorce and custody battle, during which Alex would at one point stare at her from the dock and tell the court, "she doesn't have any good qualities."
这是我1999年录下的磁带。Violet最终成为了Alex的妻子，然后多年后，在他的极度痛苦的离婚和监护权争夺战中，Alex一度从被告席盯着她并告诉法庭，“她没有任何优点。”
You're beautiful, my love. Isn't my girlfriend, Violet Nichols, beautiful and smart? Look at her. Look at her. She is just incredibly smart. That's the webmaster of infowars.com.
你很美，我的爱。我的女朋友Violet Nichols不是很漂亮又聪明吗？看她。看她。她简直聪明得不可思议。那是infowars.com的网站管理员。
I followed Alex around for weeks that year. He was different back then, an eccentric fledgling conspiracy broadcaster. I can't remember him attacking anyone but the powerful in those days. He wasn't going after victims of school shootings as crisis actors. He didn't assert, as he did in 2017, that the yogurt maker Chobani was, quote, importing migrant rapists who were spreading tuberculosis. He later apologized to Chobani in the face of a lawsuit.
那一年我跟着Alex跑了几个星期。那时的他不同，一个古怪的羽翼未丰的阴谋广播员。我不记得他在那些日子里攻击过任何人，除了强者。他没有去追求校园枪击案的受害者作为危机演员。他没有主张，正如他在2017年所做的那样，酸奶机Chobani是，引用道，进口正在传播结核病的移民强奸犯。面对诉讼，他后来向Chobani道歉。
He has money now, a workforce of something like 40 employees, and a fan in President Trump, who has repeated a bunch of theories championed by Alex that Barack Obama is a Muslim who wears a ring with an Arabic inscription. That Ted Cruz's father was linked to the JFK assassination, that Obama and Hillary co-founded ISIS. Alex is playing a role in propagating the misinformation and confusion that's permeating America.
他现在有钱了，有40名员工的劳动力，还有特朗普总统这个粉丝，他重复了Alex倡导的一堆理论，即巴拉克·奥巴马是一个戴着有阿拉伯铭文戒指的穆斯林。泰德·克鲁兹的父亲与肯尼迪遇刺有关，奥巴马和希拉里共同创立了ISIS。Alex正在扮演一个角色，传播充斥美国的虚假信息和混乱。
With Hillary, she is an abject, psychopathic demon from hell that as soon as she gets into power, is gonna try to destroy the planet. Folks, let me just tell you something-- there are dozens of videos and photos of Obama having flies land on him indoors at all times of year, and he'll be next to 100 people, and no one has flies on 'em.
关于希拉里，她是一个来自地狱的卑鄙、精神病恶魔，一旦她掌权，就会试图摧毁地球。伙计们，让我告诉你们一些事——有几十个视频和照片显示奥巴马全年都在室内有苍蝇落在身上，他旁边有100个人，没有人有苍蝇。
Hillary, reportedly-- I mean, I was told by people around her that they think she's demon-possessed, OK? You can't wash that evil off, man. I'm told there's a rotten smell around Hillary. I'm not kidding. People say Obama and Hillary both smell like sulfur. They smell like hell.
希拉里，据报道——我的意思是，有人告诉我说他们认为她是恶魔附身，好吗？你洗不掉那份邪恶，伙计。有人告诉我奥巴马和希拉里闻起来都有硫磺味。他们闻起来像地狱。
Anyway, back to my meeting with Josh.
不管怎样，回到我和Josh的会面。
I was a big listener of the show.
我曾经是节目的忠实听众。
He said working for Alex had been his dream job. He'd actually won an online reporter contest four years earlier to work for Infowars. He was a young and angry Alex Jones fan back then, committed to exposing the shadowy elites. But now he was disillusioned, because Alex had changed. And the final straw was the Muslims.
他说为Alex工作一直是他的梦想工作。他实际上四年前赢得了一场在线记者比赛，从而为InfoWars工作。他当时是一个年轻而愤怒的Alex Jones粉丝，致力于揭露阴暗的精英。但现在他幻灭了，因为Alex变了。最后的稻草是穆斯林。
Alex had lately been broadcasting untrue stories about American Muslims running secret terrorist training camps in the Catskill Mountains of New York, and cheering the 9/11 attacks. Here he is talking to then-candidate Donald Trump.
Alex最近一直在广播关于美国穆斯林在纽约卡茨基尔山脉运营秘密恐怖训练营，并为“9·11”袭击欢呼的不实故事。这是他在和当时的候选人唐纳德·特朗普谈话。
You are vindicated on the radical Muslims celebrating not just in New Jersey, but New York, Palestine, all over. What do you have to say? They're still attacking you.
你被平反了，关于激进穆斯林不仅在新泽西州，而且在纽约、巴勒斯坦各地庆祝。你有什么要说的？他们还在攻击你。
Well, I took a lot of heat, and I was very strong on it. I just want to finish by saying your reputation is amazing. I will not let you down.
嗯，我承受了很多压力，我对此非常强硬。我只想最后说，你的名声太棒了。我不会让你失望的。
And so Josh had found himself intimately involved in the business of demonizing Muslims. This wasn't why he'd signed up. These weren't powerful elites. They were regular people. Recently, Josh boarded a plane and sat next to a Muslim family. The little girl was laughing, her face pressed to the window. Josh looked at her, and he hated himself. And soon after, he began texting me.
所以Josh发现自己深入参与了妖魔化穆斯林的业务。这不是他报名参加的原因。这些不是有权势的精英。他们是普通人。最近，Josh登上一架飞机，坐在一个穆斯林家庭旁边。小女孩在笑，脸压在窗户上。Josh看着她，他恨自己。不久之后，他开始给我发短信。
He wanted to make amends. He said he knew he should quit working for Alex, but it was hard. Alex paid him well. And although he had seen Alex scream at people in the office, and punch cabinets, and rip down blinds, he'd only ever been nice to Josh.
他想弥补。他说他知道他应该辞去Alex的工作，但这很难。Alex付给他很高的报酬。尽管他曾见过Alex在办公室里对人尖叫，并打柜子，撕下百叶窗，但他对他一直很好。
As we continued to talk, I realized that Josh hadn't come to tell me any specific secret about Alex. He just wanted to vent his frustrations to somebody else who had known him a long time. But then he said, oh, here's a story. The thing Josh told me then would, if true, totally rewrite the story of how Alex Jones became Alex Jones.
当我们继续交谈时，我意识到Josh并没有告诉我关于Alex的任何具体秘密。他只是想向另一个认识他很久的人发泄他的挫折感。但然后他说，哦，这里有个故事。Josh当时告诉我的那件事，如果属实，将彻底重写Alex Jones如何成为Alex Jones的故事。
First, you should know that Alex has a kind of origin story about what got him obsessed with rooting out conspiracies. He's told it a few times to the Rolling Stone journalist Alexander Zaitchik, and during monologues on his show.
首先，你应该知道Alex有一个关于他沉迷于根除阴谋论的起源故事。他曾几次告诉《滚石》杂志记者Alexander Zaitchik，并在他的节目独白中说。
When I was, like, 16-years-old, and I'd be at parties, in would come a sheriff's department car, and they'd come in and sell bags of drugs to people.
当我大约16岁的时候，我去参加聚会，警长部门的车会开进来，他们会进来卖毒品给人们。
This took place in the Dallas suburb of Rockwall, where Alex grew up.
这发生在达拉斯郊区的Rockwall，Alex在那里长大。
And I went to school, and they were having an auditorium meeting about drug testing, or something. They had cops up there that I knew were drug dealers. And I stood up, and I said, "I was at a pool party. He was selling cocaine and ecstasy last week." They took me in an office, rammed my head in the wall, told me, "we're gonna kill you if you don't shut up." They said, "You're gonna move out of this town right now." That's why we moved out here to Austin, because of it.
我去学校，他们正在礼堂开会讨论药物测试，或其他什么。他们有警察在上面，我知道他们是毒贩。我站起来说，“我在参加泳池派对。他上周在卖可卡因和摇头丸。”他们把我带进办公室，把我的头撞在墙上，告诉我，“如果你再不闭嘴，我们就杀了你。”他们说，“你现在就搬出这个城镇。”这就是为什么我们搬到Austin，因为这个。
Police corruption in Rockwall had opened Alex's eyes to the existence of powerful cabals, and exposing them would become his calling. And it all began at that school assembly. So that's Alex's origin story.
Rockwall的警察腐败打开了Alex对有权势帮派存在的认识，揭露它们将成为他的使命。这一切都始于那次学校集会。所以这就是Alex的起源故事。
But according to Josh, it wasn't true. The true story, he said, was much more revealing. And it was also a big secret. Josh said, OK, I've heard this story a couple of times from childhood friends and family members.
但据Josh说，那不是真的。他说，真实的故事更具启发性。而且这也是一个大秘密。Josh说，好的，我从儿时朋友和家人那里听过这个故事几次。
Very few people in the office know it, but when Jones was a teenager, he was a bully. No one liked him, because he was a bully. There was a group of kids that felt unsafe around him, and so they came up with a plan to trick him. They invited him out to a party in a barn. It was a trap, Josh said. They beat him within an inch of his life. That's why his family moved to Austin.
办公室里很少有人知道它，但当Jones是青少年时，他是个恶霸。没人喜欢他，因为他是个恶霸。有一群孩子觉得在他身边不安全，所以他们想出了一个捉弄他的计划。他们邀请他去参加一个谷仓里的派对。Josh说，那是个陷阱。他们把他打得半死。这就是为什么他的家人搬到了Austin。
His whole family uprooted him and moved into a completely different city because of this crazy thing that happened to him. Josh said having those guys conspire against Alex by luring him to that party was the real reason he got obsessed with conspiracies. He had been the victim of one.
他的全家因为这件发生在他身上的疯狂事情而连根拔起，搬到了一个完全不同的城市。Josh说让那些家伙通过引诱他去那个派对来密谋对付Alex，是他沉迷于阴谋的真正原因。他成了其中一个受害者。
Josh and I parted soon after that. I walked around, replaying our conversation and wondering if I should look into it further. There were now two Alex Jones origin stories. In Alex's version, he was a brave figure forced out of town for standing up to corrupt authority. But in Josh's, he was an outcast run out of town by fellow high school kids.
Josh和我在那之后不久分手了。我四处走动，重温我们的谈话，想知道我是否应该深入调查。现在有两个Alex Jones的起源故事。在Alex的版本中，他是一个勇敢的人物，因为反抗腐败权威而被逐出城镇。但在Josh的版本中，他是一个被高中同学赶出城镇的弃儿。
Had Alex still been the fringey Alex of the '90s, I would have left his childhood alone. But he had become an influential figure, spreading chaos. And according to Josh, being ambushed at that party was the moment that shaped him-- that made him who he was. And so I dug around some more.
如果Alex仍然是90年代那个边缘的Alex，我会让他的童年独自留着。但他已经成为一个有影响力的人物，传播混乱。而根据Josh的说法，在那个派对上遭到伏击是他塑造自己的时刻——那让他成为了他。所以我又挖了一些。
It became really clear, really quickly that Alex's school assembly story did not stand up to scrutiny. My producer, Lina Misitzis, reached 10 people who were at the school at the time. And while it's true that the local sheriff had been convicted of stealing marijuana from the police evidence room with a plan to sell it, no one remembered anything like that assembly happening. Not the students, not the principal, not the teachers, not one of Alex's old football coaches, Randall Talley, who preferred to go by Coach Randy.
很快就很清楚了，Alex的学校集会故事经不起推敲。我的制作人Lina Misitzis找到了10个当时在学校的人。虽然当地警长确实因为从警察证据室偷窃大麻并计划出售而被定罪是真的，但没有人记得发生过那种集会。不是学生，不是校长，不是老师，甚至不是Alex的老足球教练之一Randall Talley，他更喜欢被称为Randy教练。
Do you remember an assembly where Alex called out the cops in the assembly for being drug traffickers?
你还记得Alex在集会上点名警察是毒贩的集会吗？
Well, I didn't know about that.
嗯，我不知道那个。
Is that your first time hearing about it?
这是你第一次听说它吗？
Yes.
是的。
Here's a former classmate, Ryan Tipton.
这是前同学Ryan Tipton。
No, not at all. That was probably DARE-- the DARE program. And I do not remember that at all.
不，一点也不。那可能是DARE——DARE项目。我根本不记得那回事。
Here's an old school friend, Jacob Olsen.
这是老朋友Jacob Olsen。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Who told you that? No. No.
谁告诉你的？不。不。
And Lina found the police officer who actually worked in the school when Alex was there, who presumably would have been one of the drug dealing cops who beat up Alex. His name is Terry Garrett.
Lina找到了在Alex在那里时确实在学校工作的警察，大概他会是打Alex的贩毒警察之一。他的名字是Terry Garrett。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, that sounds like something he probably would say, but I don't think anything like that ever happened. I mean, I would be willing to bet my whole pension that that never happened. I mean, I don't think there were any times where, actually, we were even questioning a student, that an administrator wasn't in the room.
好的，那听起来像是他可能会说的话，但我认为从来没有发生过那种事。我的意思是，我愿意拿我整个养老金打赌那从来没有发生过。我的意思是，我不认为有任何时候，事实上，我们在审问学生时，办公室里没有管理员在场。
What everyone does remember about Alex is, well, how memorable he was. We were emailed the same stories over and over from former classmates. Quote, "he used to run through the hall saying he was the devil. This is no joke." And, "he spoke a lot about being Satan or the Antichrist." And, "he would walk the halls with his arms flared out, with this intense, wide-eyed, evil look in his eyes." And, "he proclaimed to be the Antichrist."
每个人都记得关于Alex的是，嗯，他是多么令人难忘。我们一遍又一遍地收到前同学发来的同样的故事。引用道，“他过去常跑过大厅说他是魔鬼。这不是开玩笑。”还有，“他说了很多关于成为撒旦或反基督的事情。”还有，“他会走过大厅，手臂张开，带着那种强烈、睁大眼睛、邪恶的眼神。”还有，“他宣称自己是反基督。”
Here's Coach Randy.
这是Randy教练。
I'm fixing to tell you something that's gonna blow your mind. He-- oh, golly. People thought he was possessed. Have you heard this?
我要告诉你一些会让你大吃一惊的事。他——哦，天哪。人们认为他被附身了。你听过这个吗？
I've heard this from so many students, but this is the first time I've heard it from an adult.
我从很多学生那里听到过这个，但这还是我第一次从成年人那里听到。
Well, he could make his tongue turn black. And he would roll his eyes back in his head, and he would just sort of shake his head. It was-- I don't even know how to describe it, it was so eerie.
嗯，他能让他的舌头变黑。他会把眼睛翻到头里去，他会只是那种摇摇头。那是——我甚至不知道怎么描述它，它太令人毛骨悚然了。
So you would see him do it?
所以你会看到他这样做？
Yeah, I saw him do it in class.
是的，我在课堂上看到他这样做。
And what did you think you were looking at?
你认为你在看什么？
I really didn't know if he had broke a pen, or something, you know, to get his tongue, and his mouth black, or not.
我真的不知道他是否弄坏了一支笔，或其他什么，你知道，去弄黑他的舌头和嘴。
He terrorized that high school. Just run full steam, and shove his head into the lockers, and scream, "Hail Satan."
他恐吓了那所高中。只是全速奔跑，把头塞进储物柜，尖叫，“撒旦万岁。”
This is Ellen. I'll call her "Ellen." She didn't want us to use her real name because, as she texted, "I am not afraid of Alex directly, but I am very concerned about retaliation from his followers." Ellen went to middle school and high school with Alex. She didn't remember any party in a barn where Alex got revenge attacked, but she did have lots other memories of him, like these.
这是Ellen。我会叫她“Ellen”。她不想让我们用她的真名，因为，正如她发短信说，“我不直接害怕Alex，但我非常担心他追随者的报复。”Ellen和Alex一起上初中和高中。她不记得Alex被复仇攻击的谷仓里的任何派对，但她确实有很多其他关于他的记忆，比如这些。
Sitting in art class with him, across the table-- he's over there wringing his hands, describing to me in great detail how he's going to rape me. And I never thought he would actually do that. Just shock factor.
和他一起坐在艺术课上，在桌子对面——他在那里绞着手，向我详细描述他打算如何强奸我。我从来没想过他真的会那样做。只是为了冲击力。
If Alex hadn't become famous, would you still have remembered Alex?
如果Alex没出名，你还会记得Alex吗？
Oh, yes. Definitely. You don't forget people like that.
哦，是的。当然。你不会忘记那样的人。
Then Ellen told me her worst Alex memory.
然后Ellen告诉了我她最坏的Alex记忆。
The most violent incident was-- in second period geography? Where he bludgeoned one of his closest friends to the point where he was unconscious, and bleeding, and laying on the floor.
最暴力的事件是——在第二节地理课上？他打他最亲密的朋友之一，打到他失去知觉，流血，躺在地板上。
Was that Jared?
那是Jared吗？
Mm-hm.
嗯嗯。
So when did you first meet Alex Jones?
那么你第一次见到Alex Jones是什么时候？
1990. My senior year.
1990年。我高三那年。
Jared's real name is Jared. He still lives close to Rockwall, in a mobile home in the countryside. Even though his mother, who is watching us from the kitchen, had counseled him to be anonymous, Jared was steadfast. He wanted to be named.
Jared的真名是Jared。他仍然住在Rockwall附近，在乡村的一辆移动房屋里。尽管他母亲，在厨房里看着我们，建议他匿名，但Jared很坚定。他想被命名。
Right off the bat, he was odd. Real odd, real strange. We wanted him around because it was funny at first, you know? The way he acted. But it got worse and worse, and finally, man, we just didn't want to hang out with him at all.
一开始，他就很奇怪。真奇怪，真陌生。我们想让他待在周围，因为起初很有趣，你知道吗？他的行为方式。但它变得越来越糟，最后，伙计，我们只是根本不想和他在一起了。
Jared was bewildered that a journalist had contacted him. Nobody had asked him about the day Alex beat him unconscious since high school. It was an argument over a girl.
Jared对记者联系他感到困惑。自高中以来，没有人问过他Alex打他到失去知觉那天的事。这是一个关于女孩的争论。
I said, what's going on? But he came in behind me, and pretty much just rammed into the wall, and caused me to fall off balance. It dazed me. I was blurred vision. I could see him, but he picked me up, and I just went over headfirst, and knocked me out immediately. And started-- my body went into convulsions. I started flipping all over the ground. And he just kept stomping on my head, and kicking me in the head, and kicking me in the ear. Blood came out of my ears, and my nose, and everything.
我说，怎么回事？但他跟在我后面进来，几乎只是撞进墙里，导致我失去平衡摔倒。我头晕眼花。我视线模糊。我能看见他，但他捡起我，我只是头朝下翻过去，立刻把我撞晕了。并开始——我的身体开始抽搐。我开始在地上翻来翻去。他只是不停地跺我的头，踢我的头，踢我的耳朵。血从我的耳朵、我的鼻子，和其他地方流出来。
He was trying to kill me. Point blank. What other excuse is there? I got seven fractures to the skull and and a concussion, lost 20% of the hearing in my right ear. I live with a headache pretty much all the time. I get pretty bad headaches.
他想杀我。明目张胆地。还有什么借口？我的颅骨骨折了七处，还有脑震荡，右耳听力丧失了20%。我一直带着头痛生活。我的头痛相当厉害。
Jared said the parents took over after that. Alex's father, a dentist, offered to pay Jared's medical bills, including a $10,000 neurologist's bill. But there was a condition.
Jared说在那之后父母接管了。Alex的父亲，一名牙医，提出要支付Jared的医疗费，包括一张10,000美元的神经科医生账单。但有一个条件。
Y'all just don't jump on Alex. Just leave him alone. I'll pay all the bills. So I just left him alone.
你们都不要找Alex的麻烦。只是别管他。我会付所有的账单。所以我只是别管他。
Jared said Alex's father also gave Jared's parents a book about why it's wrong for people to sue people. Lots of people remember Alex beating Jared up. Here's Coach Randy, who broke up the fight.
Jared说Alex的父亲还给了Jared的父母一本关于为什么人们起诉别人是错误的书。很多人记得Alex打Jared。这是Randy教练，他制止了那场打斗。
Oh, golly. Alex had him upside-down. Do you know what a pile driver is?
哦，天哪。Alex把他倒挂着。你知道什么是打桩机吗？
No. What is it?
不。那是什么？
You literally have the person with his feet up in the air, and his head down between your legs. And you just drop to the ground, and the first thing that hits is your butt and his head at the same time.
你确实有人的脚在空中，头在你双腿之间。你只是掉到地上，第一件事撞到的是你的屁股和他的头同时撞到。
Holy shit.
该死的。
Yeah. Holy shit.
是的。该死的。
Jared eventually returned to school. And then, one night, he was at a party. It wasn't in a barn. It was at a house, but this was the origin story that Josh the cameraman had told me. The beating in the countryside. Jared said the instigators were his friends, Mark and Brian.
Jared最终回到了学校。然后，一天晚上，他在参加一个聚会。那不是在谷仓里。那是在一个房子里，但这就是摄像师Josh告诉我的起源故事。在乡村的殴打。Jared说煽动者是他的朋友Mark和Brian。
The two guys who brought him to the party, did they know that they were taking him somewhere where he might get attacked?
带他去参加聚会的那两个人，他们知道他们带他去了一个可能遭到攻击的地方吗？
The other two guys that brought him? Yeah, they loved fighting. It's all they did. They fought all the time. They figured that me or somebody would whup him. They wanted to see it, so they brought him out there.
带他去的那另外两个家伙？是的，他们喜欢打架。那是他们所做的一切。他们一直打架。他们认为我和别人会痛揍他。他们想看，所以他们把他带到那里。
And he come in, he's been drinking, and just hooping and hollering, and carrying on. Finally, one of my buddies slapped him in the back of his hat. And I was trying not to even look at him, you know? He thought it was me, and there we go.
他进来了，他一直在喝酒，只是在那儿喊叫，坚持下去。最后，我的一个哥们儿扇了他的帽后。我试图甚至不看他，你知道吗？他以为是我，然后我们就开始了。
He just pointed me out. He just picked me and said, "Come on. I'm gonna beat your ass like I did before." You know? He started all that flipping around, and flopping around the living room, and throwing his coat, throwing his hat. Saying he's the devil, he's Satan, and he's gonna kill me. I had to. It just was ridiculous that he was able-- that he did what he did to me. I had to prove to myself, and all my friends, hey, man, this was a fluke deal, man. You know?
他只是指出我。他只是挑了我，说，“来吧。我会像之前那样痛揍你。”你知道吗？他开始在那儿翻来翻去，在地板上翻来翻去，扔他的外套，扔他的帽子。说他是魔鬼，他是撒旦，他要杀我。我必须这样做。他能做到——他对我做的事太荒谬了。我必须向我自己，和所有的朋友证明，嘿，伙计，这是个侥幸的事，伙计。你知道吗？
When I jumped on him, I hit him until I broke both my knuckles, my hands, until I couldn't hit him no more. I just reached over and grabbed this rake, this wooden handle-- steel rake, but wooden handle-- and I just thought I'd hit him in the back of the head with it.
当我扑向他时，我打他直到我打断了我两个指关节，我的手，直到我不能再打他。我只是伸手抓过这个耙子，这个木柄——钢耙子，但木柄——我只是想用它打他的后脑勺。
And it knocked him down, and when he come back up running, that's when he ran into my buddy, and that was a mistake. My buddy grabbed him by the ears and planted his knee in his face. And he just took off running. And I think two or three weeks later, they moved.
它把他打倒了，当他再次跑起来时，那是他撞进我哥们儿怀里的时候，那是个错误。我的哥们儿抓住他的耳朵，把他的膝盖种在他的脸上。然后他就开始跑了。我想两三周后，他们搬家了。
So they moved because of this fight?
所以他们因为这场打斗搬家了？
Mm-hm.
嗯嗯。
Because the Rolling Stone article said that he had uncovered some corruption in the Rockwall police force, and that's why they moved.
因为《滚石》文章说他揭露了Rockwall警察部队的一些腐败，那就是他们搬家的原因。
Yeah. No, it was definitely nothing like that. They couldn't go nowhere anymore. Nowhere to go, nobody to hang out with. Nobody just couldn't stomach him. So he knew there was nothing left there in Rockwall for him.
是的。不，绝对没有那回事。他们不能再到任何地方去了。无处可去，没人可以出去玩。没人只是受不了他。所以他知道Rockwall对他来说已经什么都没剩了。
So Josh the cameraman's story had turned out to be sort of right. But he was wrong about a couple of things. It wasn't a barn. It was a house. But more importantly, the way Josh told it, the fight was the thing that had made Alex a conspiracy theorist. But Jared said, no, that's not true. He said Alex always had his theories, even before then.
所以摄像师Josh的故事结果证明是某种程度上的正确。但他关于几件事是错的。那不是谷仓。那是一所房子。但更重要的是，Josh讲述它的方式，打斗是让Alex成为阴谋论者的原因。但Jared说，不，那不是真的。他说Alex在那之前就有了他的理论。
Yeah, he had something to say about the principal, and the teachers, and the school cop, and everybody's doing all this. If we were at the pool hall, it was the guy that owned the pool hall. And he'd done called the DEA, and they were setting a deal up. It was weird, man. Everybody was like, what?
是的，他关于校长、老师、学校警察和每个人都在做这一切有话要说。如果我们是在台球室，那是拥有台球室的家伙。他已经叫了DEA，他们正在设置一个交易。这很奇怪，伙计。每个人都在说，什么？
Hey, guys. I'm sorry I'm, like, five minutes late. I was stuck getting back to the office. I got a lot of crazy stuff going on. It's good to be here with you guys.
嘿，伙计们。我很抱歉，我迟到了五分钟。我被困在回办公室的路上。我有很多疯狂的事情正在进行。能和你们在一起很高兴。
It's a Thursday in February. Alex is talking to me from his studio in Austin. I'm at home in New York. I think the crazy stuff Alex is referring to, by the way, is that a judge has just ordered him to give a sworn deposition in the court case brought against him by some Sandy Hook parents. Alex had one condition for doing this interview. He wanted to make a brief statement. Though my story isn't about Sandy Hook, this is what he wants to say.
这是二月的一个星期四。Alex正在Austin的演播室和我交谈。我在纽约家里。我想Alex指的疯狂的事情，顺便说一句，是一位法官刚刚命令他参加由桑迪胡克父母对他提起的法院案件的宣誓证词。Alex做这个采访有一个条件。他想做一个简短的声明。虽然我的故事不是关于桑迪胡克，这就是他想说的。
So here's my Sandy Hook statement. Looking back, before I was ever sued, years ago, I reviewed the information, and I do believe the horror of Sandy Hook happened.
所以这是我的桑迪胡克声明。回顾过去，在我被起诉之前，几年前，我审查了信息，我确实相信桑迪胡克的恐怖发生了。
By the way, that's only sort of true. Even after Alex first admitted that children died at Sandy Hook, he hedged, saying "they probably died," and "I tend to believe they died."
顺便说一句，那只在某种程度上是真的。即使Alex第一次承认孩子们死在桑迪胡克，他也避重就轻，说“他们可能死了”，并且“我倾向于相信他们死了”。
I have apologized to the families many times in the last few years if my reporting has caused them any pain.
如果我的报道给他们造成了任何痛苦，我在过去几年里已经多次向这些家庭道歉。
These apologies are contentious, because he's apologized, but then continued to cast doubt on the shootings.
这些道歉是有争议的，因为他道歉了，但后来继续对枪击事件表示怀疑。
I never said that anyone should harass the victims' families. And I asked the media to please stop saying that I have said that.
我从来没有说过任何人应该骚扰受害者的家庭。我要求媒体请停止说我那样说过。
As best as we can tell, Alex never directly instructed his fans to harass the families. But on his broadcasts, he repeatedly talked about Lenny Pozner's ex-wife and son. And he gave Pozner's mailing address, and showed Google Earth shots of the building, and said he would probably have to go there himself.
据我们所能判断，Alex从来没有直接指示他的粉丝骚扰家庭。但在他的广播中，他反复谈到了Lenny Pozner的前妻和儿子。他给了Pozner的邮寄地址，并展示了该建筑的谷歌地球镜头，并说他可能必须亲自去那里。
I ask anyone else who is going to harass the families to stop. What happened at Sandy Hook and similar events is a tragedy that needs to be recognized. It's time for us to come together as Americans, and as humans, and defend the lives of children and other defenseless individuals. Period.
我要求任何其他将骚扰这些家庭的人停止。桑迪胡克和类似事件发生的是需要被承认的悲剧。现在是我们作为美国人，和人类团结起来，保卫孩子和其他无助个人的生命的时候了。句号。
Alex declined to answer follow-up questions about Sandy Hook. I got to the business at hand.
Alex拒绝回答关于桑迪胡克的后续问题。我手头还有事。
OK, so there's a guy in Rockwall called Jared, but I think you knew him maybe as Bubba.
好的，所以Rockwall有个叫Jared的家伙，但我认为你可能把他当作Bubba认识。
Oh. Oh, I remember Bubba, who was a senior, and I was, like, a freshman, coming and getting me out of class. And he was, like, a hall monitor, so he could do it. And then he attacked me in the hall, so I defended myself. And I'm sad that he got put in a coma, but that's just what happened.
哦。哦，我记得Bubba，他是一个高三学生，我像个高一新生，来到这里让我离开课堂。他是个大厅监视员，所以他能做到。然后他在大厅攻击我，所以我捍卫了我自己。我很难过他陷入了昏迷，但这就是发生的事。
I've never talked about this stuff, and I'm not particularly proud of it, but I always defended myself. I never started fights.
我从来没谈论过这些事，我不特别为它感到骄傲，但我总是捍卫我自己。我从不发起打斗。
This is different to Jared's version, by the way. In Jared's account, Alex started the fight. Also, Jared said he wasn't in a coma, but he was hospitalized for multiple skull fractures.
顺便说一句，这和Jared的版本不同。在Jared的叙述中，Alex发起了打斗。此外，Jared说他没有昏迷，但他因为多处颅骨骨折住院。
Jared said that he thought that you were trying to kill him.
Jared说他认为你试图杀他。
Well, when a 250 pound-- he would be a self-described redneck, and you weigh 160 pounds, starts attacking you, you defend yourself. So the way it works in America is, when someone physically attacks you, and you defend yourself, you're not the bad guy.
嗯，当一个250磅的——他会是自称的乡巴佬，而你重160磅，开始攻击你时，你捍卫你自己。所以在美国运作的方式是，当某人身体上攻击你，而你捍卫你自己，你不是坏人。
By the way, Alex does confirm parts of Jared's story. He remembers his father paying the medical bills, though he doesn't recall a book about why it's wrong for people to sue people.
顺便说一句，Alex确实证实了Jared故事的部分内容。他记得他父亲支付了医疗费，尽管他不记得一本关于为什么人们起诉别人是错误的书。
I felt real bad. My dad went and visited him at the hospital. I mean, we weren't happy about it. And I mean, that's the story you've got? What about the time-- I mean, you didn't hear about the time, like, 20 people attacked me?
我感到非常难过。我爸爸去医院看望了他。我的意思是，我们对此并不高兴。而我的意思是，这是你拥有的故事？那次怎么样——我的意思是，你没听说过那次，比如，20个人攻击我？
Well, the other story I heard was you were at a party, and some of Jared's friends attacked you. So was that the story that you mean?
嗯，我听到的另一个故事是你当时参加一个聚会，Jared的一些朋友攻击了你。那是你的意思的故事吗？
No, that never happened. So what supposedly happened at that?
不，那从来没有发生过。那据称在那发生了什么？
The story I heard is this. It all started with Jared, with the geography, and then you were at a party, and some of Jared's--
我听到的故事是这样的。这一切始于Jared，地理课，然后你在参加一个聚会，Jared的一些——
I told Alex everything Jared had said about the ambush.
我告诉Alex关于埋伏的一切Jared说的事情。
And that's why you left town, was because of that party. That's the story that I heard.
这就是为什么你离开城镇，是因为那个聚会。这是我听到的故事。
Total, complete horse crap. Total Shakespearean fiction. So what happened is, I wasn't that big of a guy, and everybody would start fights with me. I mean, this is just total fiction, totally made up. You didn't hear the part where the captain of the football team attacked me in the lunchroom, and I literally took on the entire senior football team?
完全、彻底的马屁。完全的莎士比亚式虚构。所以发生的是，我不是那么大的家伙，每个人都会开始跟我打架。我的意思是，这完全是虚构，完全编造的。你没听到足球队长在午餐室攻击我，我真的承担了整个高级足球队的部分吗？
No, I did not hear that.
不，我没有听说过。
That was an epic fight. That was like Hercules. It was like Popeye. Like, pow, pow, pow. It was just, like-- it was the greatest trip of my life. I mean--
那是一场史诗般的战斗。那就像海格力斯。那就像大力水手。就像，砰，砰，砰。它只是，像是——那是我一生中最伟大的旅行。我的意思是——
Later, we talked to Alex's old friend Jacob, and one of the football players, and Coach Randy, and no one remembers it this way. At best, Jacob said, Alex fought off two or three football players. Which is actually still quite impressive.
后来，我们和Alex的老朋友Jacob，以及足球运动员之一，还有Randy教练谈过，没人记得是这样。充其量，Jacob说，Alex击退了两三个足球运动员。这实际上仍然令人印象深刻。
And then, like, the whole football team, the whole senior team charges me, like a phalanx. And I just-- pow, pow. I mean, it was the best. So I thought you were actually getting to that story.
然后，就像，整个足球队，整个高级队像方阵一样冲向我。我只是——砰，砰。我的意思是，它是最好的。所以我以为你实际上在谈论那个故事。
No.
不。
I mean, poor Bubba starting a fight with me, that was a minor conquest. I tell you what, if Bubba wants to have a charity, get in the ring with me today, I'll do it. He's a big old tough guy. Let's get in the ring right now.
我的意思是，可怜的Bubba开始跟我打架，那是小征服。我告诉你，如果Bubba想有个慈善，今天在拳击台上跟我比，我会做。他是个大块头的强硬家伙。让我们现在就上台吧。
Well, he said he has to be very careful with his skull.
嗯，他说他必须非常小心他的头骨。
Well, he physically attacked me. Like, Ronson, if I came up and punched you in the face, would you have a right to defend yourself?
嗯，他身体上攻击了我。就像，Ronson，如果我走过来打你的脸，你会有权利捍卫你自己吗？
I would have a right to defend myself. I think it's unlikely that I would defend myself, because--
我会有权利捍卫我自己。我认为我不大可能捍卫我自己，因为——
Here's the thing, Jon, did I ever punch you in the face?
这是事，Jon，我曾经打过你的脸吗？
You've never punched me, Alex.
你从来没打过我，Alex。
Was I ever threatening physically to you?
我曾经对你身体上有威胁吗？
No. Never.
不。从来没。
Well, let's be honest. Have I not been a big old sweetie Teddy bear?
嗯，老实说吧。我难道不是一个大块头的可爱泰迪熊吗？
It's true. On a personal level.
这是真的。在个人层面上。
Alex is adamant that the party did not happen. But we confirmed that it did. We talked to two people besides Jared who say that they were there. One is named Marty Bottoms. He says he personally attacked Alex. The other is Mark Milton. When he phoned my producer Lina, she was asleep. He was on his tractor, but Lina recorded it as best as she could.
Alex坚称那个聚会没有发生。但我们证实了它确实发生了。我们和除了Jared之外的两个人谈过，他们说他们当时在那里。一个叫Marty Bottoms。他说他亲自攻击了Alex。另一个是Mark Milton。当他打电话给我的制作人Lina时，她睡着了。他在他的拖拉机上，但Lina尽其所能录下了它。
I'm probably gonna lose you when I drop down this rock, girl, but yeah, this is Mark Edward Milton.
当我在那块岩石上掉下去时，我可能会失去你，女孩，但是的，这是Mark Edward Milton。
Mark said he remembered Alex beating Jared unconscious in geography. And then he said this.
Mark说他记得Alex在地理课上把Jared打到失去知觉。然后他说这个。
We all ended up going to a party, and then some of Bubba's friends jumped him that night.
我们最后都去参加了一个聚会，然后Bubba的一些朋友那天晚上跳向他。
This was at a party after Alex beat up Jared?
这是Alex打Jared之后的聚会？
Yeah. Yeah, this was at Mark's house, out there in McLendon-Chisholm.
是的。是的，这是在Mark的房子里，在McLendon-Chisholm外面。
So he moved to Austin after that party?
所以他在那个聚会后搬到了Austin？
Yeah, they sold the condo over in Lakeside Village. And he couldn't take it from him being jumped by a couple of boys that was Bubba's friends, and he moved out of there.
是的，他们卖掉了Lakeside Village的公寓。他不能忍受他被Bubba的几个朋友跳向，他就搬出去了。
This is the story Josh had told me in the hotel lobby, and that Jared told me. It's the story Alex swears is untrue. Alex's family wouldn't talk to us, so I can't say exactly why they finally moved out of Rockwall. In our interview, Alex retold the story of the school assembly, but he also named other reasons for their move. Like how his Austin-born mother was homesick, and fed up with all the fighting. In the end, what seems clear is that this fight happened, and the assembly where Alex outed the drug dealing cops probably never did.
这就是Josh在酒店大堂告诉我的故事，也是Jared告诉我的。这是Alex发誓是不真实的故事。Alex的家人没和我们谈过，所以我不能确切地说他们最后为什么搬出Rockwall。在我们的采访中，Alex重述了学校集会的故事，但他还提到了他们搬家的其他原因。比如他Austin出生的母亲是如何想家的，并且受够了所有的打斗。最后，似乎清楚的是这场打斗发生了，而Alex曝光毒贩警察的集会可能从来没有发生过。
If I had to guess, I would say that Alex has replaced a true story, where he's humiliated at a party, with a different story where he's a hero, standing up to corrupt cops and getting beaten up for his bravery. In a way, it's same story as the one where the whole football team came at him in a phalanx. It's the character he plays on Infowars, the beleaguered hero attacked from all sides, bloodied but undaunted, and emerging the victor. It's like stories little kids tell about themselves.
如果我要猜，我会说Alex用一个不同的故事替换了一个真实的故事，他在聚会上被羞辱了，他在那儿是个英雄，反抗腐败警察并因为他的勇敢被打。在某种程度上，这和整个足球队以方阵向他冲过来的故事一样。这是他在InfoWars扮演的角色，被四面八方攻击的饱经忧患的英雄，流血但未被击倒，并成为胜利者。这就像小孩子讲述关于他们自己的故事。
Alex disputes most of the other things that people told me about him. He says he did not pretend to be the Antichrist in high school, says he didn't roll his eyes back in his head or dye his tongue black. He says he never told a classmate how he would like to rape her. He calls all of that insane garbage. He says he doesn't punch cabinets, or rip down blinds in the office.
Alex反驳了人们告诉我的关于他的大多数其他事情。他说他在高中没假装是反基督，说他没把眼睛翻到头里去或者把舌头染黑。他说他没告诉同学他想怎么强奸她。他称那所有都是疯狂的垃圾。他说他不在办公室里打柜子或撕下百叶窗。
During our reporting, something very strange kept happening. It happened during Lina's call with Mark, the tractor man. Mark's daughter, Chelsea, was listening on mute as he was telling Lina how he knew for certain that the police assembly story was a lie. Just then, Chelsea unmuted herself and said to her father--
在我们报道期间，一些非常奇怪的事一直在发生。它发生在Lina和拖拉机男人Mark的通话期间。Mark的女儿Chelsea在静音时在听，当时他正在告诉Lina他如何确定警察集会故事是个谎言。就在那时，Chelsea取消了静音，对她的父亲说——
Nobody knows what he found out about the cops, so you can't speak and say all the reason why he left Rockwall. Because he might have found out stuff that you didn't even know about.
没人知道他关于警察发现了什么，所以你不能说话说他离开Rockwall的所有原因。因为他可能发现了你甚至不知道的事情。
It kept happening. All these people who knew for sure that Alex had been a liar back in Rockwall. A lot of them believed that what he says on Infowars might be true. They have a reference for him, like Coach Randy.
它一直在发生。所有这些确信Alex在Rockwall时是个骗子的人。他们中的很多人相信他在InfoWars上说的话可能是真的。他们对他有崇敬，像Randy教练。
I agree with so many things what he says. A lot of people just think it. Alex goes ahead and says it.
我同意他说的很多事情。很多人只是想它。Alex继续说出来了。
But not Jared. Actually, Jared had somehow gone through life not realizing that Alex was a radio host. And when I brought it up, it was awkward.
但不包括Jared。事实上，Jared不知怎么走过人生没意识到Alex是个电台主持人。当我提出来时，它很尴尬。
And you know who's a fan of his now? Donald Trump.
你知道现在谁是他的粉丝吗？唐纳德·特朗普。
Is he?
是吗？
Yeah. Donald Trump's been on his show. He talks about what a great reputation Alex has.
是的。唐纳德·特朗普一直在他的节目上。他谈论Alex有着多么伟大的名声。
I could tell that Jared didn't want to hear that President Trump was an Alex fan. He gave me a look to say, "are you fake news?"
我看得出来Jared不想听到总统特朗普是Alex的粉丝。他给了我一个眼神说，“你是假新闻吗？”
With the media and stuff, I don't know. I mean, I don't know what to-- I don't know. I wouldn't-- I don't know to believe that or not.
关于媒体和那些东西，我不知道。我的意思是，我不知道该做什么——我不知道。我不会——我不知道要相信那个还是不相信。
He likes him. They like each other.
他喜欢他。他们互相喜欢。
Do they?
是吗？
Yeah. It's like all of that craziness that happened at Rockwall High School, Alex and making stuff up, and now Donald Trump's a fan. The fact is, he's carried on saying all of these crazy things, but it's no longer about the school or the pool hall. Now it's about the globalists and the Muslims. People believe him now, including the president.
是的。就像发生在Rockwall高中的所有疯狂事件，Alex和编造事情，而现在唐纳德·特朗普是粉丝。事实是，他继续说所有这些疯狂的事情，但它不再关于学校或台球室。现在它关于全球主义者和穆斯林。人们现在相信他，包括总统。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
I mean-- I mean, who's to say. I mean-- I mean, some of the stuff he says could be true. It could be. I mean, Obama, he could be a Muslim. He could back them up, the radical Muslims. And he could have been giving them money behind-- I mean, who knows? We don't know. I mean, we hear what they want us to hear. We see what they want us to see. I mean, anything could be anything.
我的意思是——我的意思是，谁说得准。我的意思是——我的意思是，他说的一些事情可能是真的。它可能是。我的意思是，奥巴马，他可能是穆斯林。他可以支持他们，激进穆斯林。他可以在背后给他们钱——我的意思是，谁知道呢？我们不知道。我的意思是，我们听到他们想让我们听到的。我们看到他们想让我们看到的。我的意思是，任何事情都可以是任何事情。
Jared, more than anyone, might have understood that Alex doesn't always tell the truth. But no, this is Alex's legacy, the chaos he sows in the world, the feeling that nothing can be known for sure.
Jared，比任何人，可能更明白Alex并不总是说实话。但不，这是Alex的遗产，他在世界上播下的混乱，没有任何事情可以确切知道的感觉。
Jon Ronson. He and his, producer Lina Misitzis, originally created a version of this story for audible.com, where they also did Jon's latest long form original for Audible, The Last Days of August, a deep dive into the never before told story of what caused the untimely death of 23-year-old porn star August Ames. It's available exclusively on audible.com. Audible is the world's largest producer and provider of downloadable audio books and other spoken word entertainment.
Jon Ronson。他和他的，制作人Lina Misitzis，最初为audible.com创建了这个故事的一个版本，他们也在那儿为Audible做了Jon最新的长篇原创，August的最后日子，关于是什么导致23岁的色情明星August Ames英年早逝的从未被讲述过的故事的深度挖掘。它在audible.com独家提供。Audible是世界上最大的可下载有声读物和其他口述娱乐的制作商和提供商。
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis. The people who put our show together today includes Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由Dana Chivvis制作。今天组装我们节目的人包括Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, 和 Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Sandy and Lonnie Phillips, Whitney Phillips, Dr. Kenneth Henderson, Joel Ronson, Elizabeth Scholer, David Bloom, Jonathan Kerlan, Sophia Hillsman, and Eric Newsom.
我们的执行编辑是David Kestenbaum。今天特别感谢Sandy和Lonnie Phillips, Whitney Phillips, Kenneth Henderson博士, Joel Ronson, Elizabeth Scholer, David Bloom, Jonathan Kerlan, Sophia Hillsman, 和 Eric Newsom。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can download as many episodes as you want on the This American Life app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He recently tried Axe Body Spray. You know that stuff? He didn't like it.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以在This American Life应用程序上下载尽可能多的剧集。This American Life由公共广播交易所PRX交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生。他最近尝试了Axe身体喷雾。你知道那东西吗？他不喜欢它。
You can't wash that evil off, man.
你洗不掉那份邪恶，伙计。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。